[Music]
this talk is called um
how to fathom timelessness originally
via spinozism and psychedelics
i'm going to be concerned really with
two main questions
and the first one is why would time not
be real
visibly timeless and secondly
is timelessness experiential can one
experience
being outside of time and to that i'll
give two affirmative
answers or well two and a half almost um
firstly i'll say yes via
the philosopher's spinoza's concept of
amor day intellectualis or the
intellectual love of god
um i say yes by the classic mystics
accounts
and also at the end um i'll talk about
the experience of a one of the most
potent of all psychedelic drugs 5mo dmt
let us begin then why would time not be
real um
two aspects of this the questions what
is what is time anyway and um
what is the eternal um that which is
outside of time
so we start with this what is what is
time
there are many aspects of this and um
it's obviously a huge question that no
one's um
really answered fully but i'll go
through a few aspects of time
and suggest why we might
hold the unreality of it so first of all
um time refers to duration
that is experienced change
everything you see around you is
constantly changing even if you move
your head that's change
and even if you don't if you see
complete blackness
there's still change in terms of
accumulation of memory
so you can't avoid duration in in one
well
in prosaic consciousness and everyday
consciousness duration is part of
lived experience so that's the most
common um
notion of time of course time itself
in that sense then when i say time it's
an abstraction from duration so
um the r the real thing we experience is
the change
you know the perception of the change of
of things of
of uh and of our mind and from that
whole um experience we sort of
extract um the abstraction that is
time and then often you know physics
especially we put
time on a timeline um an abstracted
spatial representation of time
so you can compare these two first of
all these two basic elements of time
first there's a lift experience duration
and then there's the abstract timeline
like with uh which is divided into t1 t2
and so on so forth which is used in
physics
and so on mathematics and whatnot
secondly
we must distinguish when we talk about
time uh
the triplicity that is past present
and future this is the essence of time
according to jeremy mctaggart it was
british
um idealist at cambridge um he wrote
this great text
in 1908 published in 1908 called the
unreality of time
where he argues that um the past present
and future
um which is the essence of time is
merely subjective
it can't really be properties of events
themselves
because they couldn't have all those
three attributes at once which she's
you know much more complicated way than
i'm explaining it but
which he then leads him on to say that
you know um
in absolute reality mind independent
reality we can't have past present and
future
um this is also of course the view of
the classic idealists
especially kant who says time is merely
a projection of our mind and doesn't
exist in
in the world out there in itself the
world in itself the lumina
the thing in itself um so anyway so we
can distinguish in time this triplicity
past present future
um and i should just emphasize this fact
that
you in in physics and science there is
no such thing as the present
moment as compared to the past and the
future
the present moment is determined by the
mind itself
so you take away the mind and you've
taken away that
fundamental aspect of time itself
um what are you left with well you can
still talk about the order of events
c series as mctaggart calls it um which
are not subjective but
objective so you know first a happens
and b and c and d then e and so on and
so forth
um this seems to be objective um
although
it comes into even that comes into
question when you consider relativity
um so there's the first i'll just
summarize so far there's the first um
pair of duration versus timeline there's
a second
um aspect which is triplicity as against
the order of events
another aspect of time very important is
what william james
called the species present that means
the
the dura the the length the duration of
the present moment
and um again this is
you can't say that this is an objective
fact a mind independent fact rather
of the universe um the species present
the length of the present moment and now
is very much determined again by
our minds and it can extend and it can
contract
um related to that
is what henry bergson calls the rhythm
of duration
or the speed of time um
and uh even this is uh very subjective
which means that um speed of change can
speed of time rather can change
according to
one's predicament humans predicament but
also according to species so
um there is evidence that different
species perceive time
um faster or slower than we do for
example a fly
might perceive our um whacking of it
um in slow motion unfortunately um
also i remember like for example my my
brother
told me this very peculiar incident uh
only some months ago where he was riding
his bike
uh very fast and suddenly a toddler ran
onto the road in front of him
and he held his brakes his back brake
but it wasn't slowing down enough
so he held the uh the front brake
and then he tipped over luckily
flew over the child and well heard
himself landing but luckily an arc that
avoided the child but anyway the
interesting aspect of that was
this is a known phenomenon um everything
to
for him suddenly became suddenly slowed
down he was sort of moving
very slowly and he could perceive the
child
the parents in disarray and and so on
um and so for him then the rhythm of
duration
speed of time will suddenly slow down
and again this was this is a subjective
aspect
of his mind due to the danger of his
predicament
so again we can say that this uh rhythm
is is subjective
not mind independent
fourthly we can consider time as the
fourth
spatial dimension uh vis-a-vis
minkowski and einstein minkowski was
einstein's mathematics teacher
um and
i mean there was before before then
before you know 1905 when the
theory of relativity came out there were
um
there were good mathematical theories
as to why there were more than three
spatial dimensions um
something really from riemann who proved
that um
you can have a geometry based on uh
multiple dimensions of space not just
the three
that we presuppose i mean aristotle said
that you know um
physicality is three-dimensional that's
just it there cannot possibly be more
without
contradiction but this seemed to be at
least theoretically mathematically
not right so riemann proved that you can
get very coherent
geometries then based on four dimensions
five
and add infinitum but
it was mankowski really who suggested
that time was a spatial dimension
which is hard to fathom um it wasn't i
mean minkowski sort of um
formulated it mathematically but this
idea was
already prevalent before him i mean even
in
um the time machine the novel you can
see this idea
from 1895 i think it was h.g wells
but anyway um minkowski einstein then
uh heralding the theory of relativity
said that times the fourth spatial
dimension
uh this was you know this is still
controversial of course i mean
spatial dimensions are unidirectional
you can go left and right up and down
forward and backwards of course but you
can't go
backwards in time it seems time seems to
be a one-way dimension
um but and bergson there was an
interesting discussion with
the french philosopher henry bergson
einstein in relation to this
um but nonetheless there
has been proof that um
one's velocity in space affects the
speed of time so the faster you go
the slower time goes relative to other
times and also
interestingly then with gravity the
closer you are to a gravitational point
uh the faster time goes as well
um now interestingly einstein
interesting to what i'm going to say
later einstein was an avowed spinozist
follower of um the philosopher benedict
de spinoza
he wrote einstein wrote in 1929 and i
believe in spanish's god
who reveals himself in the harmony of
all that exists
um so i'll talk about spinosa scott in
in a moment but to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas